i don't know if i can do this nothing
too
sell a few bonds bonds by bullets
bullets kill nazis bing bang boom
you're an american hero it's just not
how i picture getting there
the senator's got a lot of pull up on
the hill you play ball with us you'll be
leaning your own platoon in no time
not all of us can storm a beach or drive
a tank but there's still a way all of us
can fight who bows
[Music]
series e defense bonds each one you buy
is a bullet in the barrel of your best
guy's gun
who will come toward the door for
america
to carry the flag for america from home
[Music]
[Music]
each one you buy is a bullet in the
barrel of your best guy's guns from
[Applause]
[Music]
berlin
[Music]
[Applause]
we all know this is about trying to win
the war we can't do that without bullets
and bandages tanks and tents
that's where you come in every bond you
buy will help protect someone you love
keep our boys armed and ready and the
germans will think twice about trying to
get the drop off
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Applause]
you